are you still calling breath of the wild
to breath of the wild too well you can
stop because we finally have the title
of breath of the wild too and it's not
actually breath of the wild too turns
out it's tears of the kingdom uh isn't
that tears of the kingdom you know that
makes a lot more sense like who goes
around tearing up kingdoms anyway tears
of the kingdom brought with it a brand
spanking new trailer and i've gotta say
there's a lot that's implied in such a
short amount of time so much so that
i've asked mr celtic himself to assist
me in breaking down the meaning behind
all this weird runic stuff and how it
relates to princess zelda and also make
sure i'm pronouncing things correctly
it's pronouncing and hi thanks for
having me on the new trailer looks
amazing and i can't wait to get started
mr celtic thanks for being here now take
it away it's
you know what never mind let's start
with a brief summary of what happens in
the new trailer we're shown several
pieces of one giant mural that depicts
all sorts of things from a mysterious
new inhuman looking figure to a fierce
battle between an ancient people group
and ganon's minions to what could be
princess zelda herself following the
mural we're shown a few shots of link
diving from the sky using his new time
reversing powers and descending down
into hyrule atop a new larger glider
but perhaps the most interesting portion
of the entire trailer is the logo we're
shown for the game which features two
serpent-like dragons that are consuming
each other's tails in a circular loop a
historical symbol known as the auraboros
in real life which is meant to signify
the transition from life to death to
life again in an eternal cycle it's by
far the most intriguing aspect of the
new trailer because it mirrors the
strange new figures relationship with
zelda since the two are positioned
directly behind the dragon logo and are
even shown cupping their hands together
in the exact same manner up close now
for reasons that we'll expand much
further on in the video over on my
channel it's our conclusion that this
figure here is none other than the
goddess hylia like you said though more
on that in his video what i want to
focus on here is what exactly this all
means for princess zelda especially
since her current status is questionable
at best as a reminder since the first
trailer for tears of the kingdom came
out over 30 years ago
over three years ago following the
events of breath of the wild after the
defeat of calamity ganon zelda is
released from her self-imposed hundred
year shackles within hyrule castle and
is once again free to roam the
post-apocalyptic world of hyrule
alongside her heroic knight in blue
armor some time passes zelda gets a
haircut and at some point she and link
begin to explore a deep dark cave
eventually the duo stumbles upon the
corpse of ganondorf and this is where
korok seed hits the fan see zelda
herself goes down to the corpse and
apparently wakes it up which leads to
ganondorf exerting some massive surge of
power and removing the ground beneath
zelda's feet the last image we're shown
of zelda is of her glaring at us as she
falls hopelessly down into this ominous
pit and that's it all of the trailer
footage since then has featured no zelda
except for this mural see like celtic
mentioned earlier due to the appearance
of this character it's extremely likely
that this is none other than zelda
herself which makes one image in
particular stand out among the rest the
one where she's shown levitating over
malice or should i say falling into it
now at this point we've gotta ask
ourselves why would zelda be depicted in
this ancient mural falling into what can
only be assumed is malice in my opinion
it can only be due to one of two reasons
either one this depiction is an account
of a zelda who fell into malice or two
it's a prophecy about what we saw happen
to our zelda or it's both a historical
account and a prophecy at the same time
much like the tapestry from breath of
the wild which was both an account of a
past event and a prophecy of what was to
come since the auroboros logo for the
game seems to heavily imply a cyclical
loop of sorts then this mural being both
a historical event and a prophecy would
make perfect sense but that's neither
here nor there we believe that the mural
is a prophecy which begs the question
what makes zelda's descent into malice
so significant
bandit made a theory years ago following
the original trailer's release in which
he speculated that zelda may get
possessed by ganondorf since she appears
to be up close and personal with the
corpse as he awakens a situation that
will undoubtedly worsen after she falls
into the darkness below like the mural
depicts now whether ganondorf possesses
zelda or not isn't the point right now
the point is that most likely something
very very bad will happen to zelda
something so bad that the mural records
it and aonuma described it as being
darker than majora's mask in an
interview with ign in 2019 something
that will put her life in jeopardy once
again in tears of the kingdom but let's
switch gears momentarily remember that
due to a small gameplay snippet that
nintendo released separately we were
able to see the master sword itself
except it's corrupted and broken as link
holds it out to a glowing golden orb
that appears reminiscent of the tears of
light from twilight princess clearly
zelda is not the only thing harmed by
whatever is happening with ganondorf's
corpse it seems most likely that the
master sword will be broken when link is
grabbed by the malice exuding from
ganondorf given that the mural depicts a
prophecy that link will have to follow
through on in the game we can speculate
that there are seven tiers from the
goddess hylia that will most likely need
to be collected which may have been what
was shown in the gameplay snippet it's
very likely that these tiers would then
be used to repair the damaged master
sword after all we can see that the
sword will be repaired with the
intriguing blue green power as shown in
the logo and since that is the very same
color as this tier shown here and the
twin dragons logo which probably
represents zelda and hylia it can be
concluded that hylia's tears will
therefore somehow repair the blade of
evil's bane fitting since she's the one
who made it perhaps the tears will
reverse time within the blade which is
something hylia has been theorized to be
the goddess of for over the past decade
and will essentially rewind time in
order to restore the sword but what good
is repairing an evil slaying blade if
there's no evil to slay this is where
things start to make a strange sort of
sense see one of the biggest complaints
about the story of breath of the wild
was that it differed too much from the
traditional more linear zelda games not
including the original of course now a
good game developer listens to consumer
feedback and adjusts their future games
accordingly and with the legend of zelda
franchise clearly this happens a lot for
some evidence recall that they
completely scrapped wind waker's sequel
and made the much grittier and darker
twilight princess instead in response to
fan outcries over wind waker's art style
or how about when they got so much
negative feedback over skyward sword's
motion controls that they added the
joystick mapping option in skyward sword
hd so perhaps tears of the kingdom will
be bringing a return to linear
storytelling in response to the fans
feedback on breath of the wild's
narrative but the question is how well
as everyone knows ganondorf do be
looking a bit crusty these days but what
if that's important see when zelda
approached him he sprung a trap and made
her fall into a dark chasm below
separating her from link and leaving her
defenseless and powerless if you'll
recall since her powers left her at the
end of breath of the wild he also then
raised the castle in order to prevent
link from entering inside and trying to
rescue her and yes i know link could
just glide down to the castle from sky
rule above but maybe the castle will be
guarded by a force field of malice or
perhaps an extremely strong tornado like
the one featured in the official game
art rendering it inaccessible to link
because the only reason ganondorf would
raise the castle and the only reason he
has in the past is to specifically
prevent link from entering the castle so
somehow i get the feeling that raising
it in tears of the kingdom is no
different but with zelda being trapped
inside defenselessly with ganondorf not
to beat a dead horse but what if
ganondorf actually does possess zelda
and transfer his consciousness and
malice into her much newer body it
wouldn't be the first time exactly and
what if the reason for all of this is to
create a much more linear story one
where we do have the freedom to explore
and complete side quests but where we
can no longer just fight the n-boss off
the bat anymore with or without the
master sword like we were able to in
breath of the wild what if in tears of
the kingdom because of what happens to
zelda we have no choice but to repair
the master sword the blade of evil spain
historically has been more than just an
evil slaying blade it's also been an
evil exercising blade like when link was
cursed by an unholy relic in twilight
princess and simply approaching the
master sword removed it the evil relic
by the way originated from ganondorf's
own power which is very similar to
malice and therefore very similar to a
malice-possessed zelda it could be that
the entire point of tears of the kingdom
is to use the tears of hylia as the
mural prophesizes in order to restore
the broken master sword to its former
power and then finally enter hyrule
castle to vanquish the evil from within
princess zelda which could then lead to
the mouse returning to ganondorf's
corpse for an epic final battle with
ganondorf link and zelda yes bandit
indeed it could as cool as that sounds
it still leaves so many questions
lingering like how exactly does this
murals prophecy tie into zelda's
apparent relationship with the goddess
hylia also how do we even know that that
is the goddess hylia and what's with the
symbolism behind the hand cupping and
oroboros dragons for all of those
questions be sure to head on over to
celtic's video that's live right now
over on his channel where we crack down
and cover exactly that and a huge thanks
to the man himself for helping out with
this theory thanks for having me for a
closer look at why we think this figure
could be the goddess hylia jump over to
my channel thank you all so much for
watching and if you feel the will of
highly eliting you please consider
leaving a like on this video to get it
spread around on youtube a little bit
more and subscribe if you haven't
already for many more videos to come
huge thanks as always to my bandit crew
who make my day every day and to those
who have been supporting me via my brand
new kovi page seriously you guys mean
the world to me follow me on my socials
and that's about all i've got in this
one this is bandit looking forward to
seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you